[Musik]
namaste ab kessel wie geht's euch was es
heißt aber ich bin in indien fieber oder
wir machen jetzt gleich den ganzen
bollywood-film berauscht wir versuchen
über suchen echt nicht so die länge zu
ziehen weil heute kommt das wirklich das
stark angefragte mango schicken rätsel
und das ist seit eben typisch indisch
die in berlin dass ich liebe das auch
und daher zeige ich euch jetzt hier
schritt für schritt wie ihr das ganz
einfach zu hause selber machen können
und keine sorge ist keine
unterbrechungen in form von in welchen
tänzen oder so so wie ihr das kennt
daher fange ich an mit dem
hähnchenfleisch hähnchenfleisch habe ich
hier schon in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten sag ich mal
und gibt es jetzt in meinem beschichtete
pfanne ich habe ich ein bisschen
kokosfett drin
ihr könnt auch sonnenblumen oder rapsöl
verwenden
das ist gar kein problem und dass wir
jetzt von beiden seiten angebraten und
in der zwischenzeit auch salzen und
pfeffern
[Musik]
falls ihr euch jetzt wundert wo stehen
die ganz genauen mengenangaben und die
zutaten die stehen bei mir immer unten
in der video beschreibung das heißt
unter dem titel einfach mal aufklappen
und dann könnt ihr euch da direkt
einfach mal screenshot machen und
einkaufen gehen und ich nehme jetzt hier
auch schon meine curry passte ich
persönlich nehme gerne die gelbe karte
passt es gibt noch die grünen und die
rote wenn ich solche schaaf möchte nimmt
gerne die rote ich mag es nicht schafft
da hier einmal die gelbe karte passe die
gebe ich jetzt in den topf meine hühner
vielleicht habe ich ja vorher entfernt
das kommt nämlich gleich noch mit dazu
und dazu kommt auch noch tomatenmark und
ich habe auch schon sieben klein oder
gewürze die gebe ich auch schon mit dazu
was bei mir nicht fehlen darf ist
natürlich knoblauch ich persönlich mag 2
bis 3 knoblauchzehen wenn es nicht so
knoblauch lass dich mögt dann nimmt auch
gerne ein aber eine muster mindestens
rein das ist meine meinung dazu können
wir gerne in die kommentare schreiben
auch fanseiten wir lieben knoblauch
[Musik]
so anschließend nach circa eineinhalb
minuten kommen kurkuma und kreuzkümmel
mediation wichtig ist dass wir das ganze
ist wirklich auf niedriger stufe nur
dürften also nicht braten ich nehme hier
zum beispiel stufe 4 von 9
so ein kleiner richtwert für euch und
jetzt gehen wir in die pfanne ein
bisschen zucker beim mango chutney und
generell alles andere ist ja auch so ein
bisschen süßlich und das wird eigentlich
eher so ein so ein süßliches herzhaftes
gericht also alle die das man gegessen
haben die wissen ganz glaube ich dass
meine das karree mobilisiert jetzt schön
also ungefähr 30 40 sekunden
noch so ein bisschen mit schwenken hier
alles dann lösche ich das ab mit mango
schatten das findet ihr fertig zu kaufen
ich kann euch gerne mal das rezept dazu
zeigen ist auch super easy das lösche
ich dann wie gesagt damit ab und dann
kommt auch schon kokosmilch mir dazu wer
keine kokosmilch mag der kann sie auch
ganz einfach weglassen
[Musik]
was auf jeden fall in einen mann mit
schicken gehört ist joghurt das habe ich
jetzt schon mit dazu gegeben und es
lasse ich das ganz langsam einmal auf
köcheln und in dem moment kommt jetzt
das fleisch zurück in den topf in die
pfanne hilfe gehen wir das fleisch
zurück und das darf dann zehn minuten
lang schön köchin ist es ihnen auch
schon gar die sind auch gerne mit
dazugeben und gleich werde ich meine
mango in schöne kleine würfelchen
schneiden das zeige ich euch und die
gebe ich dann nach den zehn minuten mit
dazu lasse das ganze dann noch mal fünf
minuten so ein bisschen mit köcheln und
dann sind wir eigentlich auch schon
fertig danach könnt ihr nur noch salzen
und pfeffern
[Musik]
also ich gehe zum schluss immer noch
ganz gerne koriander rhein am liebsten
frischen dastehen lässt sich das fach
tiefgekühlten genommen aber koriander
ist immer so typisch indisch und dazu
gibt's bei mir eis ganz klassischen
basmatireis wenn ihr meine rezepte reich
sehen möchte schreibe ich gerne in die
video beschreibung
ansonsten sind wir schon durch leute
ruckzuck und wir machen das auch immer
gerne für zwei tage das ist morgen davon
gut na also euch jetzt ganz viel freude
beim nachkochen schreibt mir unbedingt
wie euch das rezept gefallen hat und was
sie als nächstes sehen möchte
leicht mein video das wäre wunderbar und
ansonsten sehen wir uns auch beim
ministerrat videos hier und jetzt kommt
also in gut nur in schweren tagen sehr
gut leben
ja das ist ja auch genau habt ja auch
vielleicht filmtipps aber man nicht das
was man so kennt also etwas ganz anderes
bollywood filmtipps schreibt doch gerne
mal rein das wird nicht mega
interessiert ansonsten ja bis zum
nächsten mal schauen
[Musik]